hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal wann
und willkommen zu einem neuen video in
dem wir heute in die zwanziger reisen
werden es ist schon 100 jahre her dass
sich 1920 ja wer rechnen kann ist klar
im vorteil und ich beginne das video
hier ungeschminkt im badezimmer denn ich
möchte zuallererst das styling machen
denn die jede zeit haben auch die
zwanziger ihren eigenen stil natürlich
beleuchtet ich jetzt nur die tollen
seiten der 20 jahre das heißt styling
tanz und food warum switche ich zwischen
den sprachen und warum habe ich gerade
switchen gesagt englisch meine damen und
herren ich meine wir haben 2020 wir
sprechen eine mischung aus einsprachen
die wir jemals gelernt haben also an
johanna und wieder mal hat wie korea in
dieses video ein gedanke meine damen und
herren ich finde dass es hier total
coole look weil ich so ein ring licht
habe und richtig aus der wiese und
beauty care meine haut ist nur ultra rot
weil ich mich natürlich jetzt gerade
eben dazu entschieden habe eine
gesichtsmaske zu machen und mein gesicht
zu vielen und dass ich alles kann man
machen
ok und jetzt fragt ihr euch bei vanessa
warum kommst du denn auf die zwanziger
jahre und da sage ich euch
es gibt ein neues sky entertainment
ticket angebot für euch denn für 499
könnt ihr mal wieder skike ticket testen
welche serie aus den 20ern kann man mit
dem sky entertainment ticket schauen
natürlich babylon berlin da könnt ihr
seit dem 24
januar die neue staffel anschauen also
falls ihr in das berlin der 20er jahre
abtauchen wollt dann schaut euch diese
serie mit dem sky entertainment ticket
auf jeden fall an den link zum angebot
findet ihr unten in der video
beschreibung und nun wenn du mal schauen
was das styling der goldenen zwanziger
jahre
das ist so das make up das ist das was
sie erreichen wollen
schritt nummer eins wir müssen unser
haut porzellan mäßig schminken so
richtig wo findet ihr dass außer
befriedigen das sollte befriedigen für
das so wenn man dann plötzlich so ein
perfekter dann perfekt ist sie nicht
alles für die zwanziger porzellan haut
schritt nummer zwei wir müssen mit dem
kajal uns die augen mal alles drauf was
wir auch brauchen sind super schmale
augenbrauen augenbrauen müssen wir gar
nicht werden muss ja nur smokie sein was
ist viel effekt hat great so und müssen
wir noch viel verrückter auf dunkel wie
meine seele hörmann
smokey eyes der 20er jahre findet so
wimperntusche
jetzt kommen die lippen und auf die
freue ich mich ganz besonders denn wir
dürfen endlich mal wieder rote lippen
tragen also ich darf es immer aber nicht
will aber nein die sache so ein
halloween mein lippenstift darauf konnte
sich aus eine puppe wie clown ist also
eine puppe bratz -puppen hey was sagt
ihr zu spät natürlich sehr starkes rusch
am sie verwendet in der farbe brot das
ist mein meistens rot weiß ich hab ich
weiß nicht was ich schön künftig macht
diesen look da jetzt mit unserem
tabulosen make up fertig sind kommen wir
jetzt zu den haaren
dafür habe ich eine original trend ließ
überträgt man das drücken der rechten
seite um ein gott
das macht vor was aus um ein grad also
rein vom styling 20
ich mach jetzt einfach meine haare so in
das stirnband drehe ich die sopran und
dann sind sie da drin und halten wollen
das einzige was natürlich bei mir blöd
ist ich habe tattoos und in den 20er
jahren gab
das ist nur für vielleicht sehen wir
nach und erfuhr
also das ist von mir noch haare sind
fertig und jetzt kommen wir zum kleid
mein kleid
[Musik]
ich stehe nicht in einem leeren raum ich
bin nur in einer ecke von unserem
wohnzimmer und ich wundere mich dass es
hier mehr
gut dass wir vorne stehen nicht genug
sachen es ist zeit für ein trend look
[Musik]
keine ahnung wie sich in den 20er jahren
echte süßwasserperlen dürfen natürlich
nicht fehlen
20 jahre dekadenz auch ohne zigaretten
kaufen mit zigaretten holen sein
brauchen es nicht cool wollen wir das
auf der verpackung hält sie das auch
noch so viel schweiß entschuldigung auf
eine sache wieder vergessen die goldenen
zwanziger außen super sail den 20er
jahren haben sie anscheinend viel
schampus getrunken und kaviar und
austern gegessen aber kommt das ist also
ich hab die flasche champagner geschenkt
bekommen deswegen habe ich so peschl
einfach eine flasche champagner zu hause
so leute wir sind schon mal gewappnet 25
jahre warten was fehlt natürlich noch
der tanz genau und da gibt es einen ganz
berühmten tanz der heißesten und den
lehrern wir heute oder tanzen halt
irgendwie aber bevor wir tanzen dann
erzähle ich euch noch was von der serie
babylon berlin in der serie geht es um
den kölner kommissare gereon rath der
ende der 20er jahre nach berlin versetzt
wird um dort einen fall zu lösen
dabei zieht es ihn in die gefährliche
unterwelt der großstadt es geht um
waffen prostitution korruption und
vieles mehr
und an seiner seite die junge charlotte
ritter die in seine fußstapfen treten
möchte jetzt geht es vor allem um einen
mysteriösen fall bei dem eine
schauspielerin im studio babelsberg ums
leben gekommen ist aber die frage ist
war es wirklich ein unfall oder doch
mord also ich kann nur sagen dass die
serie wirklich empfehlenswert ist und
nicht ohne grund so einen riesen hit
geworden ist deswegen ich verlinke euch
alles in der infobox dort kommt ihr zum
sky entertainment ticket angebot für 499
könnt ihr es testen und nun steigen wir
ins berliner nachtleben der 20er jahre
und lernen tanzen schwitzen denn 2020
würde man sagen ich lerne jetzt antic
dogdance how to dance charts um ein wort
das sie so schwer aus
[Musik]
vor linkes bein zurück da hatte ich doch
egal was du glaubst dazutun ich glaube
nicht
[Musik]
ich glaube ich habe es bis glauben ist
ich glaube ich hab's nicht aber ich
meine dass die low -variante jetzt
müssen wir dabei ich weiß nicht warum
aber ich finde das so kompliziert kommen
bei meinem tanz tutorial das ist der
anfang jetzt
[Musik]
ich schaff gleiten so schön ich bin kein
tänzer familie gibt es jetzt die vanessa
version der 20er jahren
[Musik]
das ist so anstrengend wie kommen wir
zum kochen das kann ich besser weil
meine 20er jahre recherche habe ich
einen bisher gefunden was so besonders
aussieht und wo ich wirklich wissen
möchte wie es schmeckt das jetzt die
food teil kommen sollte ist wieder
einmal waren und willkommen zu einer
neuen folge wie schmeckt heute fragen
wir uns wie das essen aus den 20er
jahren schmeckt und unser heutiger
kandidat ist dieser ananas kuchen an
us-kunden upside down heißt er und das
hat man anscheinend in den 20 jahren
gießen als erstes wird die springform
mit butter eingefädelt so richtig schön
allet vollmacht jetzt 20er jahre party
veranstalten können nämlich gerade das
weckt eile gewesen wenn man einen grund
luftballons zu kaufen das ist jetzt
richtig schöne fertige springt und jetzt
sollen zwei esslöffel zucker auf die
springen von nummer zwei in sandy
schenke gleiche polaroid picture zum
gefahr mehr für diesen anderen dass so
viele zutaten außer anna asien scheiben
aus der dose schon seit 100 jahren gibt
es ananasscheiben aus der dosen aus dem
ananassaft mange später noch an alaska
und die kleinen schweinchen fast nicht
die ananas an bevor ihr nicht eure hände
waschen cohen jetzt kommt unsere anna
laster rein
um ein gotteshaus hallo das meine art
kuchen für die obere deko brauchen jetzt
noch kirschen und eigentlich soll man
cocktail kirschen benutzen da man aber
im deutschen supermarkt wirklich jetzt
nicht wo findet so kaiser kirchen und
nehmen können aber die waren ausverkauft
also hab ich jetzt schwarze kirche und
das kommt jetzt sollen die lücken rhein
bis heute machen wir alles mit konnten
aber damals hat man einfach da
es sieht gut aus ich sterbe wir uns um
das ihr gekümmert haben können wir den
kuchenteig machen
ich habe jetzt einen kuchenteig gemacht
der 100 gramm butter 100 gramm mehl 100
gramm zucker bisschen backpulver drei
löffel ananassaft und zweier hat sieht
gut aus und unser kuchenteig darf jetzt
zur ananas partie eigentlich hätte man
eine 23 cm springform nehmen sollen ich
hab eine 28 genommen und habe deswegen
ein bisschen zu wenig kuchenteig ich
hoffe dass es jetzt halt ein schöner
ananas pankow wird man das muss richtig
sein weil sie hat auch so drum rum und
einen der mitte und das passt nun mit
dieser form wirkung kommt jetzt in den
ofen
und dieser kurs es 30 minuten lang
backen ich denke mal 20 minuten war der
extrem dünnes aber ein paar sekunden
später
nicht mal 20 minuten drin aber ich
glaube wird ultra lecker hier haben wir
unseren kugeln der prozent sogar noch so
heißes der müssen jetzt einmal so
umstülpen weil unten ist ja jetzt oben
teller auf einmal umdrehen und deckel
auf ja natürlich will jetzt nicht ab ich
stelle den gucken jetzt mal ganz kurz
nach draußen dass er schon abkühlen kann
und dann geht es an den geschmackstest
sekunden später unser kuchen ist jetzt
abgekühlt und wir können ihn probieren
dies sei das volk amüsiert und nun
stellen uns natürlich wieder der
wichtigsten frage wie schmeckt ein
kuchen aus den 20ern appetit durch die
ananas ringe ist der kuchenteig so
saftig jetzt keine 20 jahre party feiern
ich werde das konzept für den kunden auf
jeden fall unten verlinkten dann könnt
ihr euch den selber machen der ist so
lecker wie ananas wer nie auf die idee
gekommen suchen kuchen zu machen
also leute falls jetzt auch so lust auf
die 20er jahre bekommen habe schaut euch
babylon mein gott
alles also ich kann den ganzen und damit
hoffe ich euch ja das video gefallen
wenn dem so ist dann zeigt es mir auf
jeden fall mit dem daumen nach oben und
abonniert den kanal und aktivität locker
und wirklich auch keines meiner neuen
videos mehr zu verpassen kommentiert das
video gerne um mich zu unterstützen und
dann sage ich tschüss und teils ihr
jetzt so richtig lust auf die 20er jahre
bekommen habt dann schaut in die infobox
da findet ihr die links da kommt ihr zum
sky ticketangebot mit dem sky
entertainment dicke könnte aber nicht
nur babylon berlin schauen sondern auch
andere serien highlights die game of
thrones tschernobyl oder vier blocks
alles super serien ganz zu empfehlen
schaut mal rein und ich würde sagen und
ich werde den tanz üben ich verspreche
euch wenn man so fällt macht dann passt
es schon bei dieser kuchen
[Musik]